[Music]
we've got a call
from yadira in bakersfield california
hey adira how's it going hi thank you so
much for taking my call i can't imagine
two better people to answer my question
i agree
with your question okay so it's a
two-part question
um so part one i have a wonderful
husband
i have a ton of dogs keep life
interesting i have an incredible talent
of succeed in everything i do
and i've done that by creating two
businesses
but i still find myself lacking and
finding myself really depressed and
lonely when i logically understand
that i'm super lucky and very blessed
and should not feel that way
but i do tend to feel empty and sad and
find it hard to get out of bed some days
and it's kind of just the circled around
the what's the point mentality
and then part two is because i want to
feel balanced and
accept things i don't have control over
and be able to feel happy when happy
when good things happen
i signed up for better help on john's
referral link
and i wanted to know how i can make the
most out of this program i
currently was assigned a therapist i
just spoke to her once she seems really
nice
but i want to determine if she is a good
fit and what i can do
or what i can request to help this
process be more helpful and beneficial
i've never gone to therapy and i've been
raised around people who don't believe
that therapy can help
so when i saw that you could do it
remotely i was super excited i just want
to know the best way to approach it
so i was just writing down what you're
talking um
where does this story come from that you
are your achievement
and you are the amount of
accomplishments you have and you are the
amount of
luck that you feel like you've received
from the world and then you ended this
with
i come from a family i didn't believe in
therapy so then i thought well that
answered
that question somebody told you that
somebody either modeled that for you
or told you that directly that
all your dreams would come true and when
i say dreams i don't mean money or
jobs or anything i mean the ability to
sleep at night
the ability to hug your husband or hold
hands with him when you are going for a
walk
in it to feel like you can be there
instead of wondering about an email
that's come right you could be present
who told you that where'd that come from
um i think that just
came over over a long period of time
so when i was younger i had a lot of
difficulties
um really just getting by day to day
and as i've gotten older i've just
noticed that
you know i i try to start a business it
goes great i try to start a project goes
fantastic
anything that i ever tried in the last
few years i've noticed that i succeed at
and i hear that from my husband's family
specifically that they're so
surprised that i can do anything i say
i'm gonna do it they might think i'm
crazy and i just do it
and so i it might come more from my
husband's family than my own
um where that confidence comes from
christian you talk to a lot of i'll
challenge that in a second here but i
want to get back to
starting a business christie you talk to
a lot of folks who start businesses
do you hear often that people get to the
end of it and think
and well i think it i think there's a
you know what
yeah well it's interesting because i you
know i put some research in my book on
um
even something as simple as like to-do
lists like the dopamine that's released
when you check a box so i think there's
an
there can be and i'm not i'm not the
doctor here so you tell me if i'm wrong
but i think there can be
in my life that i've experienced an
addictive nature of success and
achievement so you achieve something
it's like well what's next so i run a
half marathon i'm gonna do the full math
you become addicted to
that achievement well what how can i
push myself and there's part of that
that i think is a good quality but i
think it can be something like
i definitely have experienced that john
like i've experienced that where it's
like okay what's next
what's next yeah so you dear why are you
doing this
like why are you going to therapy why
are you making creating
successful businesses why are you
married to a great guy
um i don't know that's kind of the
reason that i'm
i'm really looking for answers so to
speak because but listen that is the
answer
if you are doing this for nothing for
achievement's sake it will always be a
vortex it'll be a black hole you'll be
jeff bezos you'll have eight trillion
dollars
and then you'll think well i guess i'm
just going to quit and go to space
because i don't have anything else to do
right because what's next and i guess i
do it for like the stability i think i
think that's what what i'm looking for
and what i would tell you stability is
an illusion
it feels good but it's never enough
and so you have to define this and it
sounds cliche and we talked about the
time
you've got to have a thing you're doing
this for
or to say it in a nerdy way you gotta
have a why
and when you just spin and spin and spin
here's the deal
you have been running you've been fight
or flight for probably your whole life
and you can't out chi you can't
outperform you can't run
from a feeling of i don't have any value
or you can't run from a feeling of
um we don't have enough around here and
so
when you come up with enough number
that's what i love what dave talks about
you need to see six months
for an emergency fund and then we're
gonna say good man we don't have a
meteorite plan
right and so we have six months
emergency fund and we're gonna move on
to the next thing
because if you keep spinning out your
wheels there then what are you gonna do
eventually your body says why even get
out of bed
just go to bed just stay here and so
what i would love to challenge you
and your husband to do is to get away
from all the
the mess and by the way you're gonna
start a business
and it's not gonna be successful and you
know what that's to be okay
you're still going to be it is right and
you're going to have another one that's
successful another one after that
successful great that doesn't define you
right it's cool and it's neat and we'll
high-five you
doesn't come from your your in-laws
they're just celebrating you right
right it comes from this idea that you
think you can outrun
change and you can outrun insecurity and
you can't
you got to sit with it and let it be
present and feel it and it's
uncomfortable and it's awful and you
won't feel like you're enough
and then as you talked about you go sit
with somebody who's a professional
here's the best thing you can do with
the counselor is to tell the truth most
people
lie that's one of the first things in
grad school they teach you is your
your clients will lie to you go tell the
truth okay tell the truth be honest
about your feelings about
what you do want to do what you don't
want to do and go somewhere with your
husband and you all sit down and say why
are we doing this
what do we want to be where we want to
go christian i talked about earlier
about
reverse engineering what enough looks
like
what does are after we paid off our
house and after everyday millionaires
and after
what are we doing get to the
why to what you're doing the where you
want to be and reverse engineer it and
then live a life that you love to live
right otherwise you can be running and
running and running and running and then
you can be like well i guess i'll just
go to space for the weekend because i
don't know what else to do
right i think it kind of feels like that
it does it does and we can't go to space
because we have a trillion dollars so we
just stay in bed and watch netflix
right right i think that'd be a great
exercise
for you to take on um you know with your
counselor yadira
of this idea of discovering what your
why is and it may not happen in one
session it may not happen in just one
five minute prayer of of being alone but
if you spend some time and dig and dig
like what makes you light up what makes
you come alive what gives meaning and
purpose to your life
can coleman talks about this on his show
john delaney talks about this in his
show i talk about different ways on my
show
but that is the that is the baseline for
everything
for every business for every
relationship for every
everything you do needs to have a
purpose
you need to have a why or else no matter
what you do you're gonna wake up the
same sinking feeling
like you don't have a purpose i bet you
do you just need to find it